i settled for crazy entrepreneur who
works with toilets for a living yeah so
a weird story
[Music]
all right aaron tartakovsky thank you
for being on the show
thank you very much and you said my last
name perfectly which is not easy to do
i've been rehearsing for quite some time
as you know uh
so i i'm very excited to talk about
what you're doing with epic clean tech
it's probably one of the best names for
a startup that i've ever heard
and i and from you know the few lines
that i read about the company i think it
does justice
to to how awesome what you're doing is
but right before we get there i'd love
to go back and
and talk a little bit about your
background and where you came from
because
you've had an interesting mix of you
know studying
both at a tuft but then at 12 university
to aipac
also and now also in investor j ventures
so
talking a little bit about who you are
and how you got
to found a company called epic clean
tech
yeah well again thank you for having me
um
yeah look you know my background it's
not a straight line
i want a lot of different places i think
on paper
what i'm doing now doesn't make a lot of
sense you know i'm
born and raised nice jewish boy from san
francisco i went to school in boston
then in boston you know i got really
involved in politics i got involved in
politics around the middle east around
us israel policy
so i always knew that i was going to
eventually go and spend more time in
israel
and i did by the way why well you know
coming from san francisco going to
boston
why why'd you get so passionate and
involved with politics there
it's you know this is a long story it's
not just about me this is more of a
family story
um so my my grandfather like a lot of
people um in israel but also a lot of
jews
and all around the world traces we trace
our roots to poland
and my grandfather you know he's a young
teenager was involved in these
you know youth zionist groups and he was
the leader of the youth zionist group in
his little shtetl
in uh in the middle of nowhere poland
and for him you know it was always a
dream
one day to have a modern day state of
israel and that's always been important
to me not just because it's in the
you know it's in what we read every day
and the haggadah and everything else but
um to have in israel is a miracle now
and i always wanted to be involved in
that
and when it comes to politics you know
america is a special place
where we can get involved in politics we
can make changes through politics
very special right i have a father who's
from who's a refuse nick from the soviet
union where the thought of going and
actually
lobbying for change with your elected
officials wasn't something that was
possible
um and i i was very aware that i had the
special privilege and so i got involved
in college
that's something that carried with me um
i studied
history and jewish studies so again on
paper
i probably should have become like a
professor or a rabbi
neither of those things happened and uh
you settled for crazy entrepreneur i
settled for crazy entrepreneur
who works with toilets for a living yeah
so
a weird story that says it all okay so
aaron you find yourself
in in tel aviv you spend some time there
and then you go to apac what do you do
at aipac
at apac i worked in development so it
was my job to
raise money um and to educate everyone
on the issues of importance to us
issues like is our relationship issues
like
um collaboration on on not just military
things but on medicine
on technology on energy and then also
focusing on big
world issues like the iran nuclear
program so those are the things that i
was really focused on when i was at apec
wow
okay and now okay so now let's just jump
forward and
what what do you do with toilets why are
you so excited and passionate about
toilets
yeah it's good it's a good question um
so at epic cleantech what we're doing is
we are basically rethinking how cities
handle both their water
and their wastewater a lot of times we
also call wastewater sewage
right you know when it comes to cities
we've essentially been doing things the
same way for about 200 years
which is to say we go buildings then to
sewers and long
complicated underground networks then
off to central treatment plants
right and that approach has worked but
we've essentially been doing things the
same way that
all of our cities we have more and more
people moving into cities about 70
percent of the world's population living
in cities by 2050 we're putting more
strain
on all of these pipes and all these
facilities that were installed 3 200
years ago
right actually we at epic we got our
roots
with the bill and melinda gates
foundation i was just about to ask
because i know that
bill and melinda they work vehemently on
this topic of of the of better
infrastructure
for toilets right absolutely yeah so the
gates foundation they had something
called the reinvent the toilet challenge
and what that said was billions of
people around the world don't have
access to clean water
and reliable sanitation we can't
continue to just build things the same
way we have been building big
complicated underground infrastructure
how do we create new
inexpensive above-ground solutions that
we can deploy quickly
so our company me and my co-founders the
start
of all of this came out of the gates
foundation of sort of designing
interesting toilet applications
and by the way the real real genesis of
the whole story goes back to the
sidewalks of tel aviv
one of my co-founders oded was walking
down the streets
of tel aviv with his little pug dog
named pauli
and paulie did his business on the
sidewalk oded was not paying attention
didn't clean up after the dog received a
a fine from a police officer who saw him
not clean him after his dog
and then him being the sort of
quintessential fiery tempered
entrepreneur
rather than paying the final moving on
with his life decided that he was going
to come up with a new 21st century
solution to clean up after dogs so like
of course some israeli entrepreneur is
going to do this
so then they they started working with
the gates foundation designing toilets
they were then presenting at a
conference here in california where
me and my father were in the audience my
father is an engineer
originally i'm an engineer in the soviet
space program before he came here as a
political wrestler
he now designs building systems
mechanical systems electrical systems
plumbing systems we said
can we take what we were doing with one
toilet for the gates foundation
put it into entire building and so what
we do is
as i said normally a building big
40-story high-rise in downtown
l.a san francisco boston or tel aviv
everything all the dirty water goes from
the building then into
the sewer what we do is we install our
system into the basement of that
building
we do two things one is we pull all of
the solids
out of the water all of the organic
solids things that we eat and then go
out of our body and we turn those into
fertilizer so this is really amazing
carbon rich fertilizer we've been using
around cities
the water we then treat and put back
into the buildings
we actually help buildings reduce their
water needs by anywhere from
90 and i saw your face and that's
that's what we call the industry the
yuck factor that people are
uncomfortable with this idea
so one important thing is that right now
we only reuse water for non-drinking
uses so for
toilet flushing oh yeah i was assuming
that you're you're also trying to make
it into a drinkable
water eventually science scientifically
we can produce any kind of water we want
but by regulation and frankly because of
the reaction of you
and other people a lot of people like
you and now we're focused on just
reusing water for things
like i said toilet flushing cooling
towers which by the way right
most of the water in buildings is for
that anyways no no
it's obviously i'm making these faces
but but it is solving a huge huge issue
and you know lack of
lack of accessibility to to to to
drinkable
water let alone you know the water for
for the toilets is a huge problem and if
you're able to
to design buildings that are allowing
for that to happen that
by the way how much potential could be
recycled from the water that we use
let's say on the average flush from a
number one or number two
so on average with all the water that a
building produces all the
dirty water that they create we can
reuse anywhere from forty to ninety
percent of it
forty to 90 which basically means that
about we can we yeah so about like
if we use now if we look at the
consumption over a week we can basically
narrow it down to
the consumption of two days out of the
week and and that
that will give us the whole runway and
then what is that going to do to the
world so let's look at the vision
further ahead and say let's say you're
able to implement this
in every building in new york and every
building in sf
what what impact and how does this then
later on impact you know the more
the developing areas or are you not
concerned with that yet no we absolutely
are
um this is a solution that you know
we're starting in downtown san francisco
because there's a lot of regulations and
incentives for it
san francisco is kind of the start of
what will be what we think is sort of
going to be
a revolution in how cities are are
designed in terms of the urban water and
wastewater but
a helpful analogy of how to think about
all of this
is decentralization so you can look at a
lot of different industries that have
moved away from big
centralized infrastructure to
decentralize so one really good example
is telecommunications it used to be we
used big poles and wires to connect
everything
and then with the advent of cell phones
everything became decentralized
you look at the energy industry where we
used to only be focused on big plants
coal plants
nuclear plants and then we started
decentralizing we started creating wind
farms or we started putting solar panels
on people's roofs
we're doing that same decentralization
but for the water wastewater world
we're just about 15 years behind the
energy guys but that's exactly the the
way to think of what we're doing is
exactly what they did
we're just doing it for a completely
different industry
right and how about how how do you get
the water back up
so so if i'm like on this on the second
floor does the water main does the
recycled water maintain on my floor
or is there a whole system that that
transitions it throughout the building
yeah so the good thing is that pumps we
didn't even have to invent those
we just use pumps and we can put the
water up however high we need so we're
talking now to
one project in san francisco that's 55
stories we're talking to one project in
seattle that's 90 stories so
we can get the water wherever we need to
get it incredible
and does that require the buildings to
be planned in advance for this or can
you also go into existing buildings and
and make those modifications so our
focus is on new construction um it just
makes sense easier to design before that
but in certain cases we actually can do
retrofits
and in fact uh in september of 2019 we
did a retrofit into a 35-story high-rise
in san francisco called the nema
building which is
right between the twitter headquarters
and the uber headquarters
that's our first deployment and uh and
that was a retrofit
and i'll tell you when it is a retrofit
that means that there's people in this
case there's
754 fully occupied apartments which
means
when we started making adjustments to
the pipes in the industry we call that a
hot tap
which means no matter what there's going
to be stuff coming through those pipes
so we went
in at 3 a.m which when we thought there
would be the least amount of flushes in
that building
and we kind of sat there we're all
nervous as we went up on a a ladder or
an elevator ladder
about 20 feet removed a section of pipe
moved really quickly and kind of we're
holding our breath
and guess what no flushes we got away
without
any single flushes coming on us which by
the way when you work in this industry
you do what i do
you know sometimes i'm not neatly
dressed wearing a suit a lot of
times we're getting pretty pretty dirty
but that's what you got to do
that's what you got to do to try to
build something different and new you
got to get dirty and that's
an analogy and i think it's a metaphor
not
just for us but for every new project or
every new venture
right so i mean where is this headed so
so give me sort of like you know you're
you're
as a ceo and founder what is your
timeline and vision in the head
when is it like what are the different
markets you're going after and when can
we expect this to be sort of a
mainstream thing where
you know the average person realizes
that the water that they're using in
their toilets or
in their water fountains for brushing
their teeth he's actually recycled water
from the building
yeah look you know it's as i said it's
starting in san francisco so we actually
part of the benefit of coming from
politics is we actually helped
work with a number of people to make san
francisco the first city in the entire
country
to require that all new large buildings
have to have on-site water recycling
systems so that's really good starting
in san francisco
oh wow similar legislation in california
and by the way look you know we as a
country in the united states we recycle
maybe maybe two or three percent of all
of the wastewater we produce
if you look at a country like spain
they're number two in the world at
around 34 for 35 percent
israel is closer to 90 so israel
basically
sets the bar for what we how we should
be thinking about water how we should be
israel recycles 90
of its water it recycles 90 of all all
of its all of its waste water that they
produce yeah
oh my oh i had no idea wow israel
israel's uh israel is a world leader
when it comes to
water and water innovation i mean it
kind of makes sense we have to have
water in the desert and we only have
this tiny cleaner at which one year is
great one year it's
dried up so we we can we can't take too
many risks
aaron how did you i mean did you think
you would get
into this business you know as you're an
aipac or or as you're
i mean as you're going through your life
did you realize you you wanted to build
a company that does
you know such a major you know impact
and a big social impact actually i
you know ever since i was young i always
knew that i wanted to be involved in
things that were having
a very positive impact on the world yeah
i didn't know what that looked like yet
some people know from day one i want to
be a doctor i want to be a pilot i want
to do this i want to do that
i didn't know what the hell i wanted to
do i thought i was going to go to law
school i thought i was going to try this
at one point i wanted to be a chef i
wanted to be a veterinarian
but what i knew sort of the the one
guiding light for me was that i wanted
to do something that was going to have a
big
impact on the world and frankly i
couldn't see myself doing anything that
wasn't sort of
impact focused and so for me i didn't
know much about water i didn't know much
about the environment i didn't know much
about climate change or all these big
sort of sustainability issues but
i knew that i could learn i'm a quick
learner
and i knew that if i was doing something
that i cared about
i would be able to add in all the other
important stuff i would be able to add
in the technical skills and everything
else and that's what happened with epic
before we
officially formed epic i spent about six
months just talking to
everyone that he had even sort of a very
basic connection to what we were doing i
spoke with
building developers architects engineers
i spoke with scientists i spoke with
professors
i went to farmer's markets and went up
to the people and said hey would you use
treated human waste on your crops
and i just talked to everyone to just
find out what are the problems what are
the red flags what are the things i
should be looking out for
and we just learned we just learned and
you know there's an element of
we got lucky that five five years ago if
you ask someone can we recycle
wastewater buildings they would say
i don't know and now we have laws in the
books in san francisco and in california
that make it possible
so you know i think it to me when i talk
to other sort of people thinking about
going into starting ventures and
becoming entrepreneurs
you don't need to know all the answers
you just need to be someone who's
comfortable with the fact that you're
not going to know all the answers
one time and how many how many other
players are in this market right now
that are
that are sort of working on similar
problems like you are
when it comes to our competitive
landscape i can name all of uh
all of those people on one hand wow
wow okay so so definitely i mean when
you get to a point where where a nation
or
a large city decides that it's important
enough to make a law out of this
and for any new construction and and
you're only one of a few that are
able to to do this i think i think
you're in a pretty good position and
what
other things around the world not now
that you're you know you have experience
in looking at these different day-to-day
things that we might take for granted as
you know
not we don't even i never even thought
about the water that we that we're
wasting
to our toilet system what other things
can we be hopeful
looking for that we can sort of
revolutionize and and make a positive
impact on the world
look i'll tell you one thing i'm excited
about is that before i started epic
i ran business development marketing for
a large engineering company my father's
company
and one of the things that i did was i
ran the internship program which means
i reviewed every single application that
came in
and i'll tell you the one almost almost
every single application had one thing
in common which was that
they wanted to be part of a company that
was focused on sustainable design that
was focused on creating healthier
greener and more sustainable buildings
and so when i look at that
that to me tells me that there's a whole
new generation of engineers who frankly
build the world
that are focused not just on building
things but on building things better
and sort of creating a better future so
when i look at that i'm not just looking
at my industry i'm looking at every
single industry
and this new wave of the top engineers
and this is how they're being trained
and this is how they think
i'm really optimistic you know i think
when people
you know when you think about something
like climate change um you know people
kind of always want to find what's the
solution where should we be investing
billions of dollars and
you know what i believe is there's no
one sort of there's no one silver bullet
but instead we need to use what we call
silver buckshot we need to do a ton
of different solutions all at the same
time and that's a quote by the way
borrowed from bill mckibben who's a very
well-known climate activist
and uh you know i think really
you know as i mentioned when we only
recycle three percent of the wastewater
in this country
that means we have a long way to
innovate and which means it's exciting
there's so many different things we can
be doing
that's what keeps us excited at epic
cleantech no no definitely and
is the business of of doing something
like epiclean deck
you know i'm coming from it from a much
more sas oriented place
and i'm thinking immediately okay yeah
so you raise your seed and then you
build your mvp and then you
raise a huge institutional round and you
and you grow it and you scale it up
is that a similar model to running a
startup in the space that you're at or
or
is it much more incremental and less of
a hockey stick trajectory
yeah so look it the the basic
similarities are there
you need you know you need grit you need
to be able to
deal with failure on many different
fronts both with the product as well as
you know talking to investors and
customers but
it is a different timeline for sure
because you know the whole
move thing you know break things and
move fast that whole methodology
it's not necessarily translatable to
when you're dealing with something like
like like water where public health is
you know that there's
if you if you mess up you're gonna kill
someone or you're gonna get someone sick
so we can't take quite the same risks
plus we're working in one of the most
highly regulated
um and oldest industries out there
whereas software is still
you know in many ways it's still the
wild west where we're reinventing new
things and thinking of new things and so
however is eating the world right
it's a different approach and you know
in many cases we're more similar to kind
of
the uber model of regulatory hacking
where
it's not just new technology but you
have to figure out how to work within
existing power structures of cities
and and with industries in uber's case
with transportation which you know
you only have to read about the stories
about the taxi unions and that whole
industry was very against this
and by the way take it back even further
you know when the first trolley cars
came to san francisco you know who
fought them
all the guys who drove the horse and
buggies the horse guys well these
trolley cars are going to put us out of
business
this is what happens every single
generation finds right
innovation that's going to put them out
of business um and but for us
it's different because we're not going
to put water and wastewater plants out
of business we're actually finding a way
to work with them so we work really
closely with the utility here in san
francisco
so you know the the short answer is
our stuff is more expensive so it's and
it's a big physical heavy you know we're
talking about ten
000 pounds of metal and steel and wires
and so
it's different we don't iterate as
quickly but all of the basic
framework of how to build something new
is there which is that
you're going to find opposition you're
going to have to get in our case
literally very dirty
um but you know the basic the basic tool
kit is the same
i love it erin right before we leave i
have to ask you the most important
question
three words that best describe you
i'm gonna flip it and i'm going to say
three words that my mom would use to
describe me
that is number one son and i'm saying
that just in case either of my older
brothers adam
or joseph are listening that i now put
on the public record that i'm mom's
favorite son so there you go
i love it number one son i love it aaron
thank you very much
and i mean it just sounds incredible i
can't wait to move into
a a building that that has this and i
can proudly say that i know that i know
one of the pioneers of this
or who are making a positive impact on
the world and
it's really fascinating thank you you
ever want to tour you let me know
i just need a couple of extra clothes to
take with me and i'm happy to join in
we got that don't worry about thank you
very much have a great rest of the day
thank you bye bye